what's up guys
bang bang lunch money time well while
she's trying to get rich the rest of us
just trying to get our lunch money right
i'm here with the beautiful intelligent
polina you buy lova marinova pompliano
it's like a whole
word soup but not only actually
beautiful and intelligent she looks like
an
angel today or maybe she looks like a
artist angel angel okay uh don't forget
okay planet's getting hurt no problem
did that hurt yeah oh nobody cares oh oh
i'm in big trouble now
don't forget that lunch money is now
sponsored by block five block buy has
three products you can buy and sell
crypto
you can deposit crypto and take out a us
dollar loan against your crypto
collateral
or you can deposit a cryptocurrency or a
stablecoin and earn up to 8.6
apy in their interest bearing account
i'm an investor i said on the board of
directors
i really like the company i use it i am
a big big fan
go check it out blockfy.com pomp
again blockfy.com pomp
are you okay i feel bad about having
said that
you better this morning
uh we don't have time for this let's go
what are the topics this morning a
cardboard box
hit me in the head and then he went and
beat it up
he beat up the cardboard box the
cardboard box fell and hit her in the
head so i had to take care of business
they know
no you don't want to be a cardboard box
in our house today they got
uh pomp one cardboard boxes zero trust
me oh yeah
that that was a big punch okay it was
multiple pieces
and the box was literally dented okay
i don't know if that was from my head or
from your
nonsense i'm the one with the hard head
let's go employers added another 1.4
million jobs to the us economy in august
as the jobs recovery continued to slow
this was in line with expectations and
down from 1.7 million jobs added in july
and 4.8 million in june
but america is still down 11.5 million
jobs from february
all the job numbers are incredibly hard
to uh calculate
and the main reason is uh one it's a
moving target so all of these numbers
will get adjusted later in terms of the
actual reality these are like best
estimations basically
um there's a couple things at play one
almost 60 million people lost their job
since march and uh through the
government mandated shutdown
now you've got economies reopening so of
course people are going to bring back
their employees
what ends up happening though is uh in
june
was the bulk of people come back 4.8
million people then you had i think it
was 1.7 million
in july now you've got 1.4 so it looks
like oh we're adding less and less jobs
but that's obviously because there's
uh you know businesses are already open
they're bringing people back
now the big thing to pay attention to is
uh
where is unemployment going to kind of
settle and if uh
any of you read um the email that i
write every day
i think a couple of months ago maybe
three months ago i wrote a piece saying
you have to be uh scared of
like this huge burst of economic
activity
out of the gate like the pent-up demand
gets released so there's this you know
giant rise in terms of consumer spending
employment whatever
but then there's actually um a
kind of a false uh floor right so what
ends up happening is called a dead cat
bounce
which is it hit the ground right and it
explodes up
and everyone's like oh recovery and then
all of a sudden you get a net um
kind of drop and so in china this is
what we saw where basically
uh things dropped drastically then all
of a sudden they recovered
to almost the same level as pre-pandemic
levels
but then they fell again and it was
about a net 20
drop in economic activity right across
industries et cetera so that's what
we've got to be careful of here in the
united states
i think we're still in the hey things
are flying back
but i'm interested where are we six
months from now and kind of where do we
net out
i'm interested what will happen is
winter comes
well winter's all i mean look it is take
new york city for example
tell them about the restaurants and how
bad it would be here if winter hit
i'm just worried about the restaurants
because de blasio's saying
he won't open indoor dining until
there's a vaccine
then cuomo was like oh no no don't
listen to him working
and it's just nobody knows what the [ __ ]
is that oh can i say that
nobody knows what's happening and then
the poor restaurant
owners are like okay can you just tell
us because otherwise we're gonna like
permanently close
and in the winter time i don't care how
many outdoor heating lamps you have
nobody's gonna be outside when it's like
blizzarding and snowing and
cold as hell facts all right what's next
what we got next
okay uh softbank is exploring assembling
a group of bidders for tick tocks
india assets and has been actively
looking for local
partners god tick tock i thought they
already first of all
i thought the u.s division had to choose
a buyer on like tuesday
it's friday now we still don't know and
then what the hell is softbank doing in
india where
everything's banned well that's why they
want to buy it it's because india banned
it because it's under chinese ownership
but if softbank bought it
then they probably would allow it back
and my guess is that they think that
there's an opportunity to buy it for the
cheap
right because it's banned so what's it
worth right nothing really
um and so same thing in the united
states is obviously there's the threat
of the ban
uh look this is like a saga that never
ends
right with uh with tick tock tick tock's
still growing though
even with all the bands everything it's
still i was on it this morning
but um softbank might have a leg up
because
it has a minor steak and bite dance
which is tick tock's
parent company we'll see i mean it's
hard to tell kind of how it's all going
to play out but
tick-tock continues to be the the
darling of the tech industry
it's so crazy how that happened um
all right uh dan kaminski founder of
hedge fund marble ridge capital was
arrested and charged with fraud
extortion and obstruction of justice in
connection to neiman marcus's
bankruptcy bid so the charges are part
of an alleged bid rigging scheme tied to
the retailer's
bankruptcy wait what he sought to
suppress
allegedly a rival bid for neiman's my
teresa
assets so that marble ridge his firm
could secure the shares for a lower
price
then he attempted to coerce the rival
bidder to cover up the alleged scheme
that's not great do we think we're gonna
see more of this
during a time like this because people
are just you know
yeah i mean look he has more than a
billion dollars in assets
and it looks like uh there's all kinds
of
chaos that happened here now neiman
marcus is filing a lawsuit against the
marble ridge capital i don't know all
the details here but i think your point
is valid in that
in times of market chaos uh people get
desperate and they do desperate things
uh or they get greedy right either one
can happen but there's increased
uh fraud um and kind of nefarious
activity in these times
and so it just ends up being like look
just i think people see a situation of
things
yeah just be a good person do the right
thing well speaking of
nefarious and suspicious npr
did an investigation where
you know moderna it's like they're
developing supposedly they're
great at developing a vaccine currently
uh
allegedly there's going to be a vaccine
allegedly
but an npr examination of official
company disclosures has revealed
additional irregularities and potential
warning signs
signs where modernist stock selling
practices appear well outside the norm
and raise questions about the company's
internal control to prevent
insider trading so here's what it found
basically since june 1st
company executives have sold roughly 90
million dollars worth of modernist stock
rather than put a hold on the trades
after facing intense criticism in may
company executives continued to sell
okay
uh my favorite is so there's
modifications to the stock sale plan so
modernist says its executives
pre-scheduled their stock sales long in
advance
those schedules known as uh 10b51 plans
which is
a regulatory thing uh what's it say can
act as a defense right to insider
trading up
uh but the plans have to be in place
when executives do not have confidential
insight information
uh npr has found multiple executives
adopted or modified their plans just
before key announcements about the
company's vaccine
that has raised questions about whether
they were not public information
uh and selling to zero sorry sorry sorry
sorry
it's fine um my my favorite uh is npr
asked like one of the chief
communications people why
moderna executives modified their
10b51 plans just before major
announcements
and the man said i believe you must have
your dates wrong
and then they provided documentation of
the dates and then they just did not
comment
yeah i mean look there's all kinds of
crazy stuff that goes on
uh these stock sale plans are definitely
a
a good defense right if you're jeff
bezos i think bezos has one where he
sells like a billion dollars worth of
stock every year to help fund blue
origin
and he basically just says look i'm
going to sell a billion dollars worth of
stock regardless of where the stock
price is
if it's up great i'll have to sell less
shares if it's down i'll have to sell
more shares but i'm gonna
basically uh create a billion dollars of
liquidity for myself
with blue origin i don't care about the
stock price i don't care about what's
going on with the company i'm gonna do
this every year it's regular
well yeah it's just it's just like
programmatic in the sense of
he he explains that this is what he's
gonna do and then he follows that plan
and so no one can accuse jeff bezos
of hey you had inside information you
sold shares uh
blah blah blah for x reason right and
that's not uh okay
it's because he put the plan in place
way before what these people are being
accused of and again
you know npr this is not a a legal case
at the moment
but npr basically is alleging that uh
they
modified those stock sale plans
after they had inside information so
they basically said oh wait this is
going to happen
then they went they modified their stock
sale plans and then they just sold based
on the plan
but the plan had been modified and then
they sold within 90 days afterwards
so it's just look i don't have all the
details it's really hard to kind of
understand this stuff we don't have a
modernist
side like the executive what's their
argument here it could have a perfectly
uh defendable reason for doing this but
it just doesn't look good when it's such
big numbers so
chicks are bad and 90 million dollars by
three people it looks like
ceo sold 40 million uh i think and uh
and another guy sold like
50 or 60 likes not good
my question is like people are aware
that you cannot do this especially if
you're
at a ceo of a corporation like this
why even do something that may make the
optics
look bad so and again i can't speak for
these people right and this is all
allegations but i do think that two key
pieces to this are
one uh people will do things within the
rules so if the rule says hey if you
modify your stock plan and then you just
execute the stock point you're not gonna
get in trouble
like they're basically trying to find a
loophole right so like you could say hey
that's not in the spirit of the rule but
if you follow the rule then it's not
illegal
right so that would be one kind of
defense argument uh another thing that
could be
said is we didn't have any information
we modify it every year
right and at this time again i don't
know if that's true or not big
announcements yeah
but but it's just what if every year in
may they modify the plans right
who knows uh and then the third thing
that i will say is
uh during these chaotic times
meaning that there's a lot of frothiness
in the market companies and
executives are incentivized to sell if
they think it's overvalued right just
like when the
stock goes down if they think it's
undervalued they buy
now there's a bunch of rules around
doing this because they have access to
more information than
other people do and so this ultimately
is just going to come down to
did they break any of those rules was it
malicious did they know
of course now here's what i will say is
it's nuts that people are dumping 90
million dollars worth of stuff you mean
like don't get this confused as to i'm
defending this
it's just more so we don't have enough
information from us to say this is good
or this is bad
but absolutely the optics are uh uh-oh
this is not good so we'll see what
happens but i think that people just
gotta wait for a little bit more
information before we make a judgment
call
fair fair all right i appreciate npr
doing an investigation of something they
saw as a regular
yeah surprise npr did that they do they
do investigations
um google is telling employees to take
friday off as a collective well-being
holiday
during the pandemic uh the friday before
labor day weekend basically
they're giving employees the additional
day to help them
avoid burnout do i get a day off from
lunch money oh wait no
i don't by the way monday is a national
holiday in the united states
we're still going to do it clinton and i
decided are we
yeah we are i'm going to pull because
you'll miss my beautiful face
yeah something like that okay so so
collective well-being holiday i think
i think that's nice of google i guess i
feel like it doesn't really matter
though
i mean if you have work to do what are
you gonna do i mean they're being nice
to people that's fine
four day weekend man i used to live for
four day weekends in school
be like free day friday do you remember
furlough days
well i went to public school so you
probably didn't have those i had we had
furlough days where like the teachers
wanted to be furloughed because of like
budgetary issues
and you didn't go to school it's great
uh what i do know
is uh i used to in college i used to
call it free day friday i don't have
classes on tuesday and thursday
and free day friday minute i could just
do whatever i wanted that means you also
wednesday
and friday and monday we're also free
days
that's a little tip for you kids at home
if you only have classes on tuesdays and
thursdays you get a four day weekend
every sunday
all day free day friday free day
friday i used to love that [ __ ] all
right what's up
rapper travis scott is about to become
the first celebrity to have their name
on a mcdonald's menu since michael
jordan's mcjordan nearly 30 years ago
what well let's just see what uh it's
gonna be
he apparently loves quarter pounders
with cheese so do i
so do i travis scott coming in hot so
much they decided to name the burgers
after him for a limited time what do i
need to do to get the paulina on there
the travis scott
well you probably need to be like a
platinum artist you know have a netflix
documentary
uh i don't know i have a youtube show
have a record label
you know i have a youtube show with
you're dragging me down if it was just
me i'd be all up on there
you bet you'd be on mcdonald's venue
yeah before travis scott
what what uh what would you uh want them
to change the name of
oh i like the nuggets no i like the
double cheeseburger is that a quarter
pounder
no i think it's different with no pickle
no pickle take the pickle out
i like pickles separately but not like
jammed in my burgers all
squishy i don't like that okay so we're
thankful for your dietary restrictions
there so
so what do you think this partnership
entails do you think he's gonna get paid
for this
no he's just doing it on the kindness of
his heart i would mcdonald's
if you want somebody who doesn't want to
get paid
we're gonna have a conversation plan is
gonna learn that uh the whole point of
this is to get paid get money get paid
but
not for mcdonald's huh i just want my
name on there well i just like that
travis scott said i couldn't be more
excited to bring the cactus jack
and mcdonald's collaboration to life we
are bringing together
two iconic worlds also right over the
thing we're just
back-to-back now we started facing each
other and now we're just because i'm
trying to create like a like a uh
music album art so yeah so basically
scott's version of the quarter pounder
adds bacon and lettuce to the burger
along with a sprite
a side of fries and barbecue dipping
sauce which mcdonald's said was the
rapper's favorite meal
growing up in native houston stop
pushing me
okay guys i'll just go i'm just gonna go
over here all right so
um so that's it oh and then oh man my
joke tonight this one's gonna make you
laugh wait can i
can i say something yeah it's friday
why does jeff bezos have trouble going
to sleep every night
because he has he he has trouble
counting all his money
no because he doesn't have his pajamas
on
pajama amazon pajamas on
oh i see i said i don't know i don't
like
do you see how any anytime there's an
increase in the uh
okay listen to the intellect of the joke
okay
that was not into like those dumb okay
are you ready
sure the rock announced that he his wife
and their two daughters have recovered
from
covid ready
sure they first suspected they had it
when no one could smell what he was
cooking
[Laughter]
that's pretty good that was pretty good
that was pretty good because you lose
the sun that might be the best one well
if you have to explain the joke it's not
a good i know but and just in case
somebody doesn't get it
yeah well we know who doesn't get the
job but you laughed
thank you dad jokes read it all right
guys that's it for lunch money today
we'll see you guys on monday
while while she's trying to get rich the
rest of us trying to get our much our
lunch
money right our munch money see ya
bang bang hope you guys enjoyed this
episode of lunch money as much as we did
and don't forget lunch money is now
sponsored by block five so go check them
out there's a link in the description
that you can click on
i'm an investor a user and a huge fan
what you're a bigger fan of block five
than you are of me
block five is my second favorite thing
in the world behind polena they've got
three products
they can give you a us dollar loan you
can earn up to eight point six percent
interest on an interest bearing account
or you can buy and sell cryptocurrencies
on their crypto exchange
i personally use the interest bearing
account there's not very many places
where you'll find
up to 8.6 interest on a deposit in an
interest bearing account
go do your own research there's risk
associated but 8.6
is pretty compelling so click on the
link in the description say thanks to
the folks at blockfly
subscribe to our channel like the video
annoy pulling in the comments
and we'll see you guys tomorrow and be
kind to your friends